hey everyone it's sarah with
registerednessrn.com and in this video
i'm going to demonstrate how to read a
medication label and whenever you get
done watching this youtube video you can
access the free quiz which will test you
on this content so let's get started as
a nurse you want to be familiar with how
to read a medication label because the
medication label contains important
information that you need to know in
order to safely administer that drug to
the patient so what are some things that
you can expect to find on most
medication labels you can expect to find
the brand name followed by the generic
name the supplied form of the medication
the dosage strength the route the
medication should be administered the
total volume or a male a medication
that's in that container or vial the lot
number and expiration date medication
instructions which are very helpful for
telling you how to store the medication
or reconstitute the medication if needed
the manufacturer and distributor's name
and address a barcode and the ndc number
which is the national drug code number
so now let's look at some medication
label examples and look at where this
information can be found so here is a
mock medication label first thing i want
to cover is the brand name here the
brand name of this medication is pretend
med and the brand name is the registered
name given by the drug company who owns
rights to it and you may notice next to
this brand name a registered trademark
symbol which is an r with a circle
around it and that means it's registered
now there are patent protection rights
that are given to the company who will
solely market this medication under its
brand name so there won't necessarily be
a generic form of the drug available yet
until this patent protection runs out
now once the patent runs out other
companies can market the drug and may
create different brand names for a
medication but you should always be able
to see the generic name as well and the
brand name is usually a lot easier to
pronounce and spell than the generic
name and the first letter is capitalized
and it's usually the largest and boldest
now typically found very close by that
brand name usually under it is the
generic name and here in this example
our generic name is faux farmod and the
generic name represents the active
ingredient in the drug which is why many
times the generic name is a lot longer
and it's harder to pronounce and spell
because these names are chemicals now
there is only one generic name for a
drug there can be multiple brand names
but only one generic name and it will
always be included on a medication label
now sometimes you may be looking at a
label and you will just see a generic
name and this will be used for
medications that have been on the scene
for decades and they're very well known
by this name these names will typically
have the parentheses around them and
will all be in lower case letters now
one thing that is helpful for us nurses
is that the ending of most of the
generic names tend to be similar for
certain groups of medications which
makes it easier to identify what
medication we're giving to the patient
for example the generic names for ace
inhibitors typically end in preal like
lysinopril or beta blockers they tend to
end in lol like label to law now as a
nurse it's very important to be aware of
both the brand name and the generic name
because the doctor or whoever's writing
medications for this patient may write
you an order for the brand name but
pharmacy supplies you with the generic
name for instance the physician orders
lasix but you're supplied with frost
mine you would know that this is the
same medication and the reason for this
is because the generic form of the drug
whenever it is available tends to be a
lot cheaper than that brand name so it's
saving your patient hundreds to even
thousands of dollars and these
medications work the same it's just
cheaper for the patient so one thing you
want to keep in mind if your patient
let's say is taking the brand name at
home whenever you go to administer that
drug and it's the generic form they may
look at the pill and say hey this
doesn't look like my pill i take it home
are you sure that this is the medication
well after confirming it is you want to
educate the patient generic and brand
names those pills capsules tablets
whatever they tend to look different now
sometimes next to the generic name you
may see the letters usp what does that
mean what does it stand for that stands
for united states pharmacopoeia and this
means that that medication has passed
specific quality standards and has a
seal of approval on it it doesn't
represent a certain measurement of the
drug or how the medication is released
in the body which leads me to my next
point if a medication is designed to be
released in the body in a certain way
this type of release will be listed to
the drug's name and it will be specified
on the label for example here with this
medication label it says pretend med xr
xr is not its brand name it is telling
you that this is a different release of
the medication so xr stands for extended
release and that's even further
specified a little bit lower on the
label below the generic name it tells
you that these are extended release
capsules now there's different types of
releases some examples would be like cr
that stands for controlled release ir
immediate release ec enteric coded cd
controlled delivery and the reason i
point this out is because it's very
important the nurse looks at this part
of the medication label to verify what
type of release this medication has
because depending on the form the
medication may not be able to be crushed
or chewed because if it was crushed or
chewed and it was one of these special
releases it could alter the rate at
which the medication works in the body
and could be
not very good for the patient another
thing you want to be familiar with on
the medication is the supplied form of
the medication this tells the nurse how
the medication is supplied for example
here our label tells us that our
medication is in capsules but you can
also have medications and tablets or
even solutions and suspensions and here
you can see that this medication tells
us that it is an oral solution but this
label tells us that it is actually going
to be an injection solution because
we're dealing with something that's
going to go intravenous or intramuscular
you can also have topical suppositories
etc next is dosage strength this is the
amount of drug that is in the specific
dosage form supplied and you will see a
number with the measurement unit beside
it so let's look at this medication
label of pretend med our dosage strength
is 250 milligrams so what does that mean
well a lot of times you can go and look
at the medication instructions and it
will give you further details about this
but what this means is that each capsule
of this pretend med or faux formoid
contains 250 milligrams so let me test
you here for a second let's say the
doctor orders pretend med and they order
500 milligrams po daily how many
capsules are you going to give this
patient with each dose well we know by
looking at this label each capsule
contains 250 milligrams the ordered dose
is 500 milligrams so we're going to give
two capsules to equal that dose but now
let's look at this medication label we
have the brand name medication imagi med
has a generic name of fictitious omod
it's an injection so we're dealing with
a solution and it tells us that it has a
dosage strength of 5 milligrams per 5 ml
or also equivalent 1 milligram per 1 ml
so what that is saying is that for every
milliliter you draw up and that syringe
of that medication out of this vial you
are giving 1 milligram so it's
equivalent of drawing up 5 mls to get 5
milligrams so let me test you again here
let's say the doctor has ordered the
patient to have a one-time dose of 2.5
milligrams of this medication how much
are you going to draw up well we know
that one milliliter equals one milligram
so we are going to draw up 2.5
milliliters which will equal 2.5
milligrams and then just to give you
another example of looking at that
dosage strength let's look at this
medication label we have the brand name
fake elixir with the generic name of
mixed resolve divacate and we know that
it's an oral solution so it tells us
that it has a dosage strength of 350
milligrams per 5 ml so what that means
is that for every 5 mls that you're
measuring out you're pouring out you're
giving the patient 350 milligrams of
fake elixir so let's say the doctor
ordered the patient to have 700
milligrams once a day of this medication
how much would you pour out to give to
the patient to equal that dose well we
know for every 5 milliliters you're
pouring in there there's 350 milligrams
so we need to give 700 350 plus 350 or
700 so we would give 10 milliliters
next is the route on the medication
label you want to look to see if it
specifies what route this medication
should be given here we have a
medication in the form of capsules and
generally speaking capsules and tablets
are understood to be given orally unless
it's specified directly because some
medications may be supplied in a tablet
form but they need to be taken
sublingual or the buccal route for
instance like nitroglycerin it's like
these little tabs we give them to
patients who are having chest pain that
goes underneath the tongue and on a
bottle of nitroglycerin it will actually
say sublingual tablets so always look at
that information now there's other
routes the medications can be given for
instance here our label tells us it's
via injection and it says below that it
says for intravenous or intramuscular
you you could also with some labels it
will tell you you can maybe give it
sub-q so you can get subcutaneous in
addition other medications can be given
via the eyes the ears rectally vaginally
they can be given via inhalation nasally
transdermal so always double check that
next is total amount or volume and this
is the total amount or volume of that
medication in that container bottle or
vial whatever you have on hand and here
it tells us that there are a total of 50
capsules in this bottle now with
solutions the total amount will be
written like with a volume for instance
this vial of imagined it tells us that
it has a total of five milliliters in it
and over here with our fake elixir it
tells us that this bottle has a total of
a hundred milliliters in it after
reconstitution so once we have prepared
it the way that the manufacturer wants
us to prepare it it should have a total
of 100 milliliters in it next is the lot
number and expiration date so these two
numbers are typically located together
so the lot number is helpful in
identifying a recalled medication and to
help the manufacturer track the
medication the expiration date tells you
when the medication is expired so as a
nurse you always want to check this
especially the expiration date and you
don't want to administer an expired
medication to a patient but discard it
according to your facility's protocols
next is the medication instructions this
is a section found on most labels that's
going to give you some detailed
instructions on the medication such as
dosages how to prepare the medication
reconstitute it storage details etc so
let's look at this medication label of
fake elixir so over here it tells us
that this bottle contains a total of
seven grams of mixed result divacate and
that's just telling us that in this
whole bottle of this medication there's
seven grams of it and it's telling us
that in each five mls there's 350
milligrams of this medication so that
further gives you
information if you're a little unsure by
looking up that front part of the label
that confirms how much
is in each little dosage that you
measure out then it says the dosage see
pamphlet included with the medication
package a lot of times manufacturers
will include this little fold out piece
of paper that will tell you detailed
information about the drug if you need
to know that and then here this is one
of those ones that need to be
reconstituted so we have to prepare it
in a specific way before we administer
it right now as it is it's not ready to
go so it's telling us to add 80 mls of
water to the bottle to shake thoroughly
and this is going to prepare our 100 ml
oral solution so we want to do that
before we give that to the patient now
it's telling us that once we prepare
this medication it's going to expire in
14 days so you definitely want to label
this let other people know when this was
made and when it expires then it goes
into detail about storage it tells us
that we need to keep it refrigerated
between 35 to 46 degrees fahrenheit and
to keep it away from light next you may
see the manufacturer and the
distributor's name and address who made
this medication and who is distributing
it it can be the same name or two
different names and then you will find a
barcode on it and this is used many
times in the hospital setting to help
identify the medication in the
medication system and during
administration and lastly we have the
ndc number the national drug code number
and this is the number the fda uses to
identify drugs it has three sets of
numbers that are hyphenated the first
set of numbers are assigned by the fda
and they are the labelers code the other
numbers are given by the company and the
middle numbers are the product code and
last numbers are the package code so if
you ever see those numbers on a label
you now know what they are okay so if
you'd like to test your knowledge some
more on how to read medication labels
you can access the link in the youtube
description below and thank you so much
for watching